[APPLAUSE]
MALE SPEAKER: Good
afternoon and welcome to
Talks at Google in
Cambridge, Massachusetts.
Today it is my
privilege and pleasure
to introduce two guests from
the Boston Symphony Orchestra.
Managing Director, Mark
Volpe, and Music Director,
Andris Nelsons.
[APPLAUSE]
This is the part
where I usually do
a lot of talking
about the guests,
but really isn't music
what this is all about?
So hold on just one second.
[MUSIC - RESPIGHI, "PINES OF
ROME"]
[APPLAUSE]
MARK VOLPE: For those
who are curious,
that was Respighi's
"Pines of Rome."
That was the inaugural
concert of Andris
as our music director
for the Boston Symphony.
And that concert was seen
all over the United States
on Public Broadcasting
and all over the world
through a variety of networks.
So it's launched an
incredible relationship
or an incredible marriage.
It's now over a year,
little over a year old.
So what I thought we could
do-- and obviously we're
always curious in
what you're thinking.
But what I thought I'd do
is ask Andris a little bit
about his background, a little
bit about the art of conducting
as well as the
discipline of conducting,
and then possibly open it up
for questions from you all.
So I'll start just a little
bit about where-- you know,
I'll ask Andris to talk
about his earliest exposure.
I think you conducted your
first Ring Cycle when you
were five years old in Riga.
No.
[LAUGHTER]
But your first exposure to
classical music was Wagner.
Your mother was a musicologist.
But she took you to
a concert in Riga.
Can you talk a little bit
about that experience?
ANDRIS NELSONS: Yes.
It was very interesting
because you know,
for many, many
kids and children,
you know, the first musical
experience, listening
is probably a bit
milder than mine
was because I was
taken to the opera
and I was only five years old.
And it was Wagner's
"Tannhauser," you know.
Four and a half hour long opera
with not the most happy finish
of the opera, as we know.
But I was so amazed
and so touched
by the great, great music
of Wagner on one hand.
And from the other hand,
being in the opera theater,
experiencing lights
went down and all
of this mystic atmosphere.
Conductor coming on and
raising his hands and something
starts to sound and happen
and then this beautiful music.
And then, you know,
poor Tannhauser
died at the end of
his crying, you know.
So it was a very big
emotional show for me.
You know, I couldn't
sleep afterwards.
And then you know.
MARK VOLPE: But you went from
that and you started singing.
And then you played
the trumpet as--
and continues to
play the trumpet.
It's-- Andris now has
a-- what do you have?
A C trumpet?
And now you-- did you just
get your E flat trumpet?
Different-- trumpets
come in different keys.
And so-- before every
rehearsal and concert
you hear him practicing
and playing little things.
And the BSO players
want everyone
to understand that
it's not them.
[LAUGHTER]
I don't know if
that's a commentary
on your current quality
level, but-- but anyway, so
talk a little bit
about how you picked up
the trumpet on your
whole-- the Russian system,
their Latvian system
of music education.
ANDRIS NELSONS: Well, you know,
since that first experience--
firstly of course, my
parents are musicians.
So I was always
surrounded by music.
One or other way I always
heard music around.
Is it Bach Renaissance music,
Bach, or choir singing.
Was always around.
But of course, this
first influence
of Wagner opera age of
five made this huge impact.
And then I-- that
the same year I
started to-- the piano studies.
A music school.
So I studied for-- until age
of 12, I studied as a pianist.
And then I started
to study trumpet.
And trumpet age of 12.
And then I-- as part of
the early-- studied singing
in music school and trumpet.
And then it all got that I got
the audition, won the audition.
And I got a job at age
of 17 in national opera.
At the same opera I saw
this "Tannhauser," you know,
in the same opera house.
And I got a job.
And I was so happy of course.
And I played there for five
years as a trumpet player.
And in the meantime I also
partly studied conducting.
And--
MARK VOLPE: How do
you study conducting?
ANDRIS NELSONS: You know, the
conducting is a very mystical,
I think for one side, a
very mystical profession.
As you can see, it-- you can
see so many different conductors
doing the same piece
but so different ways.
It's all either technical waving
of arms or facial expressions
or tempo or anything.
But they are all different.
And it's not because necessarily
wanting to be different,
but it means there
is-- professional
conducting from one
hand is very mystical
because of communication
with people.
You communicate in a
concert without words.
You just communicate
the gestures
and you assume that the
orchestra understand
what do you mean.
And of course or not
understand. [LAUGHS]
Because in your gestures, in
your energy, in your facial,
you know, body
expressions, you encourage
them one or other character
or dynamic or anything what is
present in music at that point.
And of course, all of that
happens after intensive work
in the rehearsal,
of course, where
you make your relationship
with orchestra
and you build the
interpretation in rehearsal.
And I think it's
mystic because you
as a conductor don't perform
any note in the concert.
They are all playing.
So in the meantime, orchestra
could do without-- I mean,
conductor can't do
without orchestra.
Orchestra could do
without conductor.
MARK VOLPE: Conductor
without orchestra
is just moving your arms looking
like, well, never mind, a crazy
person.
ANDRIS NELSONS: So this is--
that's why it's mystical.
But there is also a very
practical and very important
part of studying conducting.
You can of course-- there are
many things you can and should
study and everyone studies.
The technique.
You read about the composers.
You study the score.
You analyze.
You compare.
You develop.
You think.
You don't sleep nights.
And because you're not
knowing what to do.
All of these things happen
when you develop as a conductor
and as a musicians generally.
And of course you develop
your skills as a conductor.
But I think that most important
is this mystical chemistry what
happens between
conductor and orchestra,
and then of course conductor
and orchestra and audience.
Because this is another
extremely important,
crucially important part
of what we do in music.
And if that happens,
there is a miracle.
And if it doesn't happen, we
sometimes can't explain why,
but if you go to the
concerts and you think,
oh, it did not touch me.
I didn't-- obviously,
we did something wrong.
If you go to the concert and
after the concert you feel,
I didn't understand
anything, but I feel great
because it was so
emotional or so depressive
or so-- whatever emotional
reaction you got-- if you got
back fulfilled
with a feeling, it
means that we did right things.
So, you know, I think
this is so much, I think,
what I think the
profession of conducting
or actually the essence of
music really brings to us.
MARK VOLPE: But
what's interesting is
if you're a violinist,
you're a pianist,
you can go in a practice
room and you can sit and play
scales and arpeggios
and then repertoire.
But if you're a
conductor, you can study
and you can learn your
theory and your music history
and all that.
But the mysticism,
the psychology,
the leadership in
terms of-- you can only
do that with an orchestra.
So it's-- when did you
start conducting orchestras?
And what was that like for you?
And were you surprised?
I mean you obviously
were a serious musician
and a family of musicians.
But when you actually get up on
a podium for the first time--
you have any recollection
when you got up
on a-- in front of an orchestra?
ANDRIA NELSONS: Yeah, the
first time I remember.
That was a-- you know,
you absolutely right.
The first step, of
course, is studying
the score and the
technique and you prepare.
But it does not absolutely
guarantee that you actually
can be a conductor
and if you would
come in front of the
orchestra or it would work.
You don't know it
until the moment
when actually first time come
in front of the orchestra.
And I experienced it.
It was at age of 17.
It was high school orchestra.
I was playing myself
in that orchestra.
The conductor who actually was
my teacher, my first teacher,
did not come to rehearsal
for some reason.
And we thought,
well-- I actually
thought, why should
be [LAUGHS] go home?
I should-- oh, let's rehearse.
I know the piece because
I'm studying conducting.
Let's rehearse.
It was Beethoven's
First Symphony.
I remember.
And I went on the
podium and I felt--
I felt so, so much at home.
You know?
I can't explain the feeling.
It's not because of feeling
of, oh, now I'm on podium,
so I can say some
things and these things
have to be done because
the way I'm saying.
It's not anything
to do with power
or-- but the joy of sharing
what I feel about music
with these musicians
and the chance
to express what I felt about
that music, in that case,
Beethoven, was so fascinating
that I thought, yes.
Now, even after have studied,
have been three years
since I studied my technique
since that moment I first
conducted orchestra
in rehearsal.
But then I only
realized, yes, I want
to continue studying conducting.
I want to become a conductor.
Because I think
before experiencing,
you can't really say whether
you actually have the ability
to come in front of
orchestra, because it's
connected, so many things.
Psychology and simply when
you prepare for rehearsal,
you know.
You can prepare
and you can think
what you will say to the
orchestra, the musicians.
But when that moment comes,
whether some people get very
shy, they can't-- you
know, they shaking,
they can't say anything because
it-- and they think, oh my god,
you know, I was so prepared.
I can't do anything.
Or opposite.
You know, there are some
people who think, oh, he
would never be a conductor.
I mean, I would--
I would think--
see people thought about
me that I-- because I was
and I am still
basically a shy person.
I'm not a person
who likes to, you
know-- I'm really a shy person.
I think everyone was
really surprised,
they saw, you conducting?
You know.
But-- and I was and when--
MARK VOLPE: Did that
include your mother or no?
ANDRIS NELSONS: On
the podium, I felt
that I can express
myself as a musician
through conducting the best way
because I forget about myself.
I'm not shy.
I just think about music.
And I enjoy sharing
what I feel about music.
And I enjoy actually the
feeling of this great teamwork
because we see-- for
me it's a teamwork.
You know, conductor,
orchestra, musicians
and to interfere to-- to
work together, you know.
That was--
MARK VOLPE: But one of
the things you said,
you know, you know
right away when
a conductor has done
his preparations
and has a few standard
stock things they want
to share with the orchestra.
But orchestras
actually-- speaking
of someone who played
in orchestra and you
played in orchestras.
That's much less effective than
someone who's in the moment
and reacting to what
was going on stage.
Because sometimes you
prepare for something.
You think there's always a few
passages in all these pieces
that are tricky,
that are rhythmically
tricky or harmonically difficult
and in terms of balance
and all of that.
And some orchestras-- you're
prepared to correct something
and it's perfect.
And then the conductor
still corrects it.
ANDRIS NELSONS: Yes, yes.
MARK VOLPE: You know,
what-- you know, I mean.
And you-- like they were so
prepared for that moment,
they can't help themselves.
And one of the great-- you
know, I hear this from all
the orchestras in Europe
and that work with you,
is that you're
absolutely in the moment
and you're-- whatever's
happening is something
you've inspired, but
it's not something
that's so premeditated
that it isn't effective.
Talk about-- a few
questions that came to me.
What's going on-- I mean,
these are all scientists.
So they're all thinking.
What are you thinking about
when we do our Google plays?
The Malher 6, the Bartok
"Miraculous Mandarin",
the Tchaikovsky Sixth Symphony.
What's going on-- we're
speaking, "Pines of Rome."
What's going on in your head?
ANDRIS NELSONS:
You know, I think
it's very interesting because
for one hand of course,
music is so directly connected
to our emotional world
and what we feel about
music, whether it's
sad or happy or
loud or aggressive
or-- you have all
ranges of music.
And of course that
you immediately,
your body reflects to
all of these feelings.
But if you analyze more,
then actually the human body
is a biological-- there's
a certain mathematics
and a huge science involved.
Of course, what-- we
thought, what is human being?
MARK VOLPE: It starts
with your heartbeat.
ANDRIS NELSONS: You know,
but it's-- but I think still
it's for us is,
for musicians is,
do we want to touch the hearts
of the listeners or musicians
on the stage and
of the listeners?
And what happens in my head,
it's-- I am trying to imagine
as deeply as I can how the
composer-- what we perform,
who we perform each
night-- either it's Mahler
or Tchaikovsky what we
already or we already--
it's already on Google Play or
on many other things which we
will-- will be possible also
to hear for Boston Symphony
on Google Play.
But any other composer,
I imagine that?
I'm living a life
of that composer
on that day when it was
performed or composed.
And that night
when we perform, I
have a feeling that the
piece was composed yesterday
and we are premiering
in the piece.
And also all these emotions
come through the head.
And what is the piece about?
What the composer experienced
in his life at that time.
So it's a huge emotional
and intellectual baggage
what you experience
being, at least in your--
in my mind and my body.
And of course,
when performing it,
you-- this is a
mystic how you get it
out of your body to the-- to
transfer to the musicians.
And that's where,
of course, it's
a combination of brilliant
fantastic orchestras, Boston
Symphony Orchestra.
Our brilliant relationship
with the orchestra,
our trust to each other,
trusting the professionality.
Also, trusting human
musicality and also
their trust in my subjective
vision about the piece.
So it's all, again, teamwork.
But there is also not-- it's
not like a exaggerate democracy
in terms of, anyone can
do whatever you feel.
Because then it's all chaos.
So it's-- I think we all are
focusing our minds and I think
the engine has to come from
me, that we are focusing
on the composer's idea, what
the composer want to present.
MARK VOLPE: But
how do you balance
the need for collective
thinking, but yet
you don't want to stymie the
individual personalities,
especially in solos?
So how does that-- you try
to establish a culture,
a way of doing it, and then you
let them give a-- you give them
a little freedom.
You give them-- how--
ANDRIS NELSONS: Yeah,
because every musician--
I mean, they are--
or the orchestras,
they've studied many years.
Some 20 and then more.
And played.
Some were playing for
already, you know, 50 years.
So-- and they've played
it so many times.
So you can't-- you know, I
think it's a giving and taking
constantly.
So when you are the conductor,
you play some certain place,
you conduct.
Let's say it's a first oboe
or first trumpet or cello,
there is a solo moment.
And I personally listen, like
listen to the soloist, how
he or she presents the
phrasing or-- and I listen
and I say, and I often
think, oh that's great.
I will follow her
or his heartbeat.
And then again, I take
initiative a little later.
And then sometimes
maybe I suggest, well,
maybe let's try to go that
route together or-- you know,
this is a constant
giving and taking
and respecting and searching
together and trusting.
It's somehow-- and
psychologically feeling when do
they need you as a conductor?
When do they need the beat?
And when they don't need
to be disturbed, you know.
It's very interesting.
There's a great
conductor, Karajan, told--
you know, it's at least like
riding a horse, horse jumping,
you know.
You don't have-- I don't ride
the horse, so I can't tell--
MARK VOLPE: We're
not encouraging
you to jump on horses
either, if that [INAUDIBLE].
ANDRIS NELSONS: So
when you conduct,
it's when, you know,
you riding the horse.
MARK VOLPE: Rhythm.
ANDRIS NELSONS: And then
you have this barrier.
And then you have to
find the right moment
where you push
the horse in order
to-- because the horse is
jumping himself of course.
But you have to
give the-- is it?
Or is it right to--
MARK VOLPE: Yeah.
You pull back and--
ANDRIS NELSONS: Go back.
And then he-- if you
constantly pull the horse,
he will throw out
you from the back.
And the same he does
with the orchestra.
If you constantly are
disturbing the orchestra,
but not in the moments
when they really need you,
you-- they don't need the
conductor at that point.
And it's so difficult. I
think it takes all your life
to really find where is this
moment where they really
need you as a conductor in
terms of purely technically
beating and also more
emotional support
and where are the moments
where you stepping out?
Not out.
But stepping aside
and letting things--
and in initiative, individuality
of each orchestra position
come forward.
And then again, where you take
initiative to take the-- all
the complex
individualities together.
So it's a very confusing,
exciting, mystical and the--
also, scientistic, I--
in that sense, I find,
because it is to do
with the heartbeat.
And the heartbeat goes
according to our inner state
of-- if you are excited,
obviously it goes fast.
If you are-- your time is
comes to leave this world,
obviously it goes
a little slower.
And so on, you know.
MARK VOLPE: Eventually it stops.
That's the bad moment.
ANDRIS NELSONS: You know, there
is a-- and the music same.
You know, the music
gets agitated of course.
Your heartbeat was faster and
then it's-- so, in that sense,
it's not mathematical,
I believe.
But it is scientistic.
Scien--?
What is the word?
MARK VOLPE: Scientific.
ANDRIS NELSONS: It's scientific
because already biological,
the body, it is a science.
It's not mathematical
maybe in that way.
But it is scientistic.
MARK VOLPE: Close enough.
It's interesting because for--
relatively speaking, I mean,
we had last week on the
podium, Christoph von
Dohnanyi who is 86.
And we were talking
about you and talking
about different things.
And I've talked to
Haitink who's 86.
It took them awhile to learn
how to trust orchestras.
And you know right
away and the orchestra
knows right away when they're
not trusted, you know,
when everything has
to be controlled
and there's no--
as you know, there
are passages-- you know
better than anybody--
that they need you.
But there are other-- and to
your grade, it's a maturity.
Talk a little bit-- I mean,
you walk through this building,
you get a sense of
a Google culture.
We talk a little bit with
our board about culture
at the Boston Symphony.
Every orchestra-- I mean,
you were just in Amsterdam.
You conduct Berlin.
You conduct in London.
Talk a little bit about the
culture that you are trying
to create and the trust and
all that and relationship
because it's-- when
you think about it--
I don't want to alarm
you-- but you know,
we're obviously
a sonic art form,
yet the most important
person makes no sound,
and so has to inspire or has to
motivate people to do what you
want.
Talk a little bit about how
you create that kind of--
ANDRIS NELSONS: You know it's,
again very, I think, individual
in a way.
And I think it's probably--
I mean, as a huge company
as Google of course, it's more
than 120 people who-- I mean,
I have orchestras
120 or something.
They have bigger chorus.
And so-- but anyway,
they-- I think--
MARK VOLPE: Google's
bigger than us.
We'll concede that right away.
[LAUGHTER]
ANDRIS NELSONS: Well,
I'm think-- but anyone
who is in charge, I think, if
you constantly dictate and say,
you should do that
because I want.
And if you don't make
the musicians to believe
or to trust or, you know,
maybe not agree as well,
but to say, OK, I
don't agree with him,
but actually the
idea is interesting.
I will follow.
At least you get to that
point because human beings
are different than--
music is so subjective.
You cannot say, one is right
and one is absolutely wrong.
I mean there are obvious
things with the tempos
or dynamic, of course,
or wrong notes probably.
It is a wrong note
at that moment.
I mean philosophically
maybe not, but-- [LAUGHS]
But you know, that
thing of trust
is very, very important
thing for conductor, I mean.
But you know, but it's
from both sides, you know.
If orchestra feels the
conductor doesn't trust them,
the orchestra doesn't
trust the conductor.
If the orchestra doesn't trust
the conductor, then-- for me,
I was playing in the
orchestra myself.
I mean it was a joke.
You know it was a bad joke.
But I think if the
conductor-- I was
a trumpet player at that
point and moment in orchestra.
When the conductor-- it's
the worst thing for conductor
was to stop and say,
well, please follow me.
And as soon as the
conductor did that--
MARK VOLPE: The game's over.
ANDRIS NELSONS: That's--
is you're finished
because everyone literally
starts to follow you.
And of course we know that
physically, physiologically,
or what-- the beat, the timing
between that-- when you're
in the show, it can't
be-- it's not really
to do with the physics.
MARK VOLPE: Yeah.
Light and sound travel, as you
all know, at different speeds.
So [INAUDIBLE] right away.
ANDRIS NELSONS: So
therefore you can't, you
can't really say that.
And you shouldn't say that.
It is rather-- I always think
it's rather the orchestra
musicians, I think
in my opinion,
is like a big, big
chamber music group.
So they hear each other.
They listen to each other.
They know what
happens in a family.
What the harps play, when-- they
know when the double bass is
or the flute plays.
And then they can follow
the line of orchestra.
And then this is like a
big, big family and organism
when you are in
the symphony, which
play-- you know, there
is one instrument group,
another instrument group.
And it's-- and it's very
interesting, I think,
also for orchestra to be
part of this organism.
And of course the
conductor, me, I
sometimes feel like a
drawing with the colors,
with this great
orchestra we have.
It's just emphasizing
one color or some darker.
Or-- and we have all
brilliant players.
And I'm just so lucky.
So that's how I operate.
I've been really lucky to have
such a great, great team, which
is again a team.
It's a teamwork with
great management
and a great orchestra and
a great, great audience
and fantastic concert hall.
And also I really,
really feel-- and we all
feel-- so honestly privileged
and very naively happy
that we can be part of this
wonderful project which
is Google Play,
and now presenting
these live
possibilities to listen
to these concerts of
these great orchestras.
And of course, Boston Symphony
Orchestra and other orchestras
because I think it is
so-- it makes us so,
so happy because it's
so important for present
and for future to share
our-- first, our great music,
classical music.
But to share it, not
only as a document,
but to share it as
an emotional act
because every concert
is really emotional act.
And every concert is different.
And then with your great help
and your great inspiration,
we make these
concerts capture them.
And then each of these
concerts are different.
And because they are live, you
can't experience it anywhere
else but just listening.
Then I think-- so I'm just
really very, very happy
about this fact because I think
there is a-- there absolutely
is a future for classical music.
And actually the future for
classical music or any-- it
is in cooperation
and in actually
looking into the
similarities, collaboration.
What is in between the art
forms-- and not only art
forms-- between other
institutions, we can find.
I mean, of course, a
great, great company
as Google Play is, is of course
a lot of science, of course.
But we have also little
science, you know.
And it's-- you-- I think
you can see the parallels,
how it works in the music.
MARK VOLPE: Sure.
ANDRIS NELSONS: Maybe
it's more mystical.
But we cooperate.
And we have this great
platform to perform
and to show how we perform
and to be proud of that.
You have a platform to share
that with their audience.
We are already doing
great things together
for classical music
and for future
of the education of humanity.
I mean, this is maybe a--
MARK VOLPE: Well, one of
the interesting dimensions
of this relationship is the
Android platform does very well
in emerging parts of the world.
They do well everywhere.
And where you see an
emerging middle class,
whether it be
China or whether it
be various parts
of South America
and other parts of the
world, all of a sudden you
see classical music.
I mean, there are 60 million
kids in China right now playing
either violin or piano.
I mean, that was
unthinkable 25 years ago,
certainly unthinkable during
the Gang of Four reign.
You know, so all
of a sudden, you
see a little capitalism,
maybe a lot of capitalism.
And you see real development of
classical music infrastructure.
We were there right prior
to Andris' ascension
as our music director.
And it's just amazing.
When Boston Symphony
was the first orchestra
to play China-- first orchestra
to play Soviet Union in '56
courtesy of Khrushchev
and then first orchestra
to play China after
normalization of relationships.
And back then they could play
in a big gym, a college gym,
and then The People's
Hall because there
was no place to play.
And now you go--
you've been to China.
There are five halls in
Beijing, including a few
they built for the Olympics.
There are three halls
in Shanghai, Guangzhou.
All this infrastructure
they're building.
And then they're looking
to us as a model,
not necessarily to
replicate because it's
a completely different culture.
A lot of these folks
I think, I have
a sense The Room
of Bindu concerts
and The Hall and all that.
But there are going
to be people watching
this that might
not have been-- so,
talk to someone who's not
heard the Boston Symphony,
not heard classical music.
What-- you've already talked
about the emotional release.
Talk a little bit about
how they should approach it
and-- because there's certain--
especially in America,
there's a certain,
oh, it's highbrow,
or it's intellectually too
difficult. I can't get there.
I didn't have it in school.
How do you overcome that?
ANDRIS NELSONS:
Yes, well I think--
I would start with a
metaphor, you know.
When we think about the
food for our physical body,
we think of certain products.
I mean, some people
like more vegetables.
Some people like fruit.
Depends what diet
you-- but you need,
certainly you need something
to eat in order to survive.
And you don't question this.
You choose what you eat.
But I think the
same is-- we have
with our emotional world
and the soul, which
is part of this-- our body.
It also needs a
source for feeding.
And I think through music
and art and culture,
this is a way you
can feed your soul.
And you can choose
whether your soul prefers
Beethoven or Mahler
or any other composer
or actually by eating
a lot of Mahler,
you actually enjoy it more.
And with some, it is
actually eating as a dessert,
not too much.
But I think, this is
that kind of metaphor
which generally, really
I can see in my life.
And I really would say
that the music is a food,
a nourishment for our souls.
It's really necessary.
We don't see it so obvious
as-- now I got a tea-- as this.
But actually when
you go to the concert
and you listen to
certain piece, you
feel you've drank a ten of the
really English breakfast, very
strong teas.
Much more than this cup.
And you can't explain.
What happened?
But you feel energized.
You can-- you know.
And that's just
because of the concert.
And even if you don't
know the composer.
But that's what the music can
give, and what the music gives.
And there's a wide
range of emotions.
If you are in love, you know,
as a teenager or as a old lady
or gentleman, you are again in
love with your husband or wife,
you can-- you go to the concert.
I don't know you go to
listen Puccini's music
or you go to Richard
Strauss or-- and then
you-- so beautiful melodies.
You start to cry.
You think, oh my god, oh, it's
so great I married this person.
Always.
It reminds-- music
reminds of some things
and reflects to
your emotionality.
And that's the
way how actually I
believe you can become
better and more sensitive.
And that's what I think
we also need in our lives.
A sensitivity and compassion and
that is what the music gives.
There is lot of ranges.
I told.
It's also-- you can-- there's
aggression in music sometimes.
There is a power.
But there is all the variety of
what you can get through music.
And the most important that
I think either children--
and it's great if it
starts in the young age,
but at any age-- that
people are simply informed
and they have this chance to
experience by either coming
to concerts or this is--
therefore, I'm saying
is such a great way also
with the great support
of Google Play.
Now many people I'm sure will
listen to these concerts.
And I really encourage
them to listen to--
for the first time
hearing it, an orchestra--
and I'm sure they
will find something
close to their hearts.
And that will be a reason
for them to listen again
or actually to come to the
concert or to ask mom, oh, mom,
I don't know what was it.
I really enjoyed that.
Can you put it again?
It's like for my daughter.
I have a small, almost
four-year-old daughter,
which is the biggest, you
know, most important thing
in my life.
And I play-- you know, she
doesn't know what the name.
But when I play, I
actually-- I got my trumpet.
MARK VOLPE: You
brought your trumpet.
ANDRIS NELSONS: Back.
But after 50 years not playing
it, I got it, the present.
So it-- and I play something.
Something.
She said, no, no, not that.
Can you do-- and I play
the slow movement of Haydn
and the trumpet concerto.
And she, yes, that's--
can you play that?
She doesn't know what it is.
MARK VOLPE: She's
already a critic.
ANDRIS NELSONS: But she says--
and I play something, ta, la,
ram, ta, dam.
No.
Dad, please shut up.
You know.
[LAUGHTER]
So there is all--
MARK VOLPE: So she
likes the lyrical,
the smoother and beautiful.
ANDRIS NELSONS: You see
that there is a soul.
Maybe it asks for that kind
of food which is more lyrical.
And that's the way.
I think it's just
evolved that we
introduce these-- the
children or any age people
with the music.
And I think there is no--
there should be no worries
or reservations because
thinking that the music is
so-called for more intellectual.
It is absolutely not like that.
It is really for everyone.
It is absolutely for everyone.
And it talks to everyone
in very individual ways.
When you go to listen
to, for example,
Tchaikovsky's "6th
Symphony" which
is our first release
in Google Play,
we know the story
of Tchaikovsky.
But when you listen
to that symphony,
whether you talk to people--
MARK VOLPE: Last movement
is just torturous.
ANDRIS NELSONS: And this
movement talks, but to everyone
it talks in different way.
It actually talks
very personally.
Everyone starts to
thinks about their lives.
And-- so there's never a
one way how the music really
approaches one, the same
people the same way.
So it is therefore-- I
just can encourage, just
take care of your soul as
well as much as your body.
Well, I can't-- don't
care of my body, you know.
But take care of your souls.
And concerts and music is a--
and art is a great, great--
and I would say, the
only way of really
getting to caring about that
part of your human being.
There is another part with
the intellect and other part,
which you need to take care.
And the--
MARK VOLPE: Music can
help with that, too.
ANDRIS NELSONS: And music
can help with that, too.
So, you know-- so just
come to the concerts.
And I am really
thankful for Google
for this great
opportunity to share.
And that is one of the ways
to get even closer to people
hearts through sharing and
through media, through that--
you are so great.
You really helping
and supporting
that because I think
this is the future.
MARK VOLPE: It's
funny when Andris
was talking about how
certain moments in music
can remind you of falling
in love with your spouse
or partner, whatever,
that I was thinking
that in the last run of
concerts, which we did here
in Boston, and Carnegie, we did
"Elektra" which is about kids
who want to kill their parents.
So I mean it kind of covers
the whole spectrum there.
It's the old Greek--
it wasn't something
that actually Strauss did.
It was something the Greeks
did 2,300 years ago or there
abouts.
Any questions?
Sir?
AUDIENCE: I just want to say
I'm so thrilled with everything
you've done so far
to energize the BSO,
both in programming
and their performance.
It's been fantastic.
I'm also really thrilled that
we got your wife along with you.
It seems like the best
two for one deal ever.
[LAUGHTER]
And that is actually
relevant to my question.
It's a good segue from
Mark's last comment, too,
because the two concerts
that I've personally
found most exciting have
been "Salome" and "Elektra."
It's just been
fantastic that you
brought those operas
to the BSO and had
such amazing
performances of them.
I wonder if you
could-- just a two part
question-- if you could talk
a little bit in general.
I know you obviously have a
deep connection with opera
from your childhood, your
wife, and all kinds of things.
I wonder if you could talk a
little bit about the challenges
of conducting opera on stage
in a place like Symphony Hall
as opposed to an actual
opera stage, first of all.
And secondly, what's the next
one that we're going to see?
And I have a suggestion if you
don't have one planned yet.
MARK VOLPE: It's already booked.
But we'll listen
and see what you--
AUDIENCE: Oh, good.
I'd like to hear that.
I'd like to hear it.
I really want to
know what it is.
I'd also love to hear you do
something like "Bluebeard's
Castle" sometime.
I think that would be fantastic.
MARK VOLPE: Have you done that?
The Bartok?
ANDRIS NELSONS: No.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Yeah. "Bluebeard's
Castle" is a short.
It's Bartok's only opera.
It's deeply psychological.
It's also fairly easy
to stage because it only
has two singers.
And there isn't a lot of
movement on the stage.
So you could really do it.
I think it'd be fantastic.
Anyway, go ahead.
You talk.
[LAUGHTER]
MARK VOLPE: New
music advisor here.
ANDRIS NELSONS: Yes.
No, no.
Thank you.
I'm absolutely
thrilled to be here.
And, as I told, amazing team I
experiencing and more and more
how great this institution is,
the orchestra and the team.
And I-- and this works
only because it's
a great team as well.
And thank you for
saying about the operas.
I mean, we enjoy every
concert of course.
But I think opera always
is-- we do it every season.
[INAUDIBLE] so far.
And this always a
great excitement
because orchestra normally
they don't play opera every day
or even every month or-- you
know, it's really not often.
And the-- besides, of course,
the musical differences--
because having more soloists
and the different music, which
is not played every
day, or the chorus
or of course-- the challenge
is which-- the technical
challenges which it brings.
There is also an extra thing
which is so healthy to develop,
I believe also, in
symphonic music,
is this way of
listening to each other
because-- and following
your-- one is heartbeat,
but actually it's
your breathing.
Because when you sing, when
you play opera-- and you,
of course, as conductor of
orchestra , your company--
a moment of soloist singing--
you can hear the soloist sings
and the-- and he or she
needs a breath and then--
so it reminds and reminds you
that making music it's to do
with a live organism, you know.
And I think by performing
opera you can really notice it.
And it works so
greatly in advance
for listening to each other,
following, supporting.
And sometimes you
come out, you feel,
oh, soloist is
running out of breath,
so we need a little help.
And you can't predict it.
You-- one rehearsal is like this
one rehearsal the other way.
And one performance
is this-- so you
need to react for me as a
conductor and the orchestra
as well.
They say, OK, so tonight
probably the soloist
had a bit of sore throat.
So we have a bit-- or-- I'm
being very, very cynical.
But these aspects,
being aware, listening,
make it very, very alive.
And I think-- I believe that
we follow that pattern actually
when we do the symphonic
concerts as well, to be
constantly alert and
dramatic, in terms
that there's a drama
in each symphony.
You know.
But I think opera is of course
very exciting thing which
we will do every season.
And then there will be
one next season, too.
So--
But thank you for
your suggestion.
That's a great opera, too.
AUDIENCE: Which one is it?
MARK VOLPE: Well, I-- we--
because of the camera rolling
here, I can't announce anything.
Next year when--
AUDIENCE: Later.
MARK VOLPE: If we're over
in the corner, I'll--
AUDIENCE: We'll
talk to you later.
MARK VOLPE: Yeah,
talk to me later.
I'll tell you because
it involves you.
You preface your
comments about Andris'
incredibly beautiful and
talented wife, Kristine.
She is going to be
with us at Tanglewood.
And since we're
announcing Tanglewood
on Friday-- Thursday?
We're going to do the
first two acts of Aida
with the BSO and Kristine.
And there are a few other
people involved in that.
But--
ANDRIS NELSONS: And
Tanglewood is also--
MARK VOLPE: Tanglewood I
don't mind telling you.
Next season, it's
a little premature.
ANDRIS NELSONS:But--
because it's-- opera.
And it's great.
But for me, as I have
conducted opera a lot,
and always the symphonic I
have played opera and orchestra
as well.
I think that they are not huge.
I mean, there is a
lot of similarities
because of the drama and how to
understand the symphonic music.
I understand it's through
the same idea of breathing,
of heartbeat, and of the drama.
You of course have
more fantasy to think
what this drama is about.
But this is-- there are some
similar elements of making
music, the way of
making music, but--
MARK VOLPE: But when we meet
with our artistic committee
from the orchestra,
and we meet with them.
We're meeting with them
tomorrow morning at 9:00
and showing them repertoire.
They-- everyone has their
own-- the brass players love
the Mahler and the Bruckner.
String players Bruckner.
Not so much.
But they all gravitate to the
opera because they don't do it.
We do it once a year, I mean.
And so for them, it's
like when the Metropolitan
Opera goes and plays a concert.
It's very special for them.
It's great because--
Andris is absolutely right,
speaking as a former musician.
It's a different-- I mean,
there are so many similarities.
It's still music.
But it's a different
approach when you're working
with singers and all of that.
And the breathing is
absolutely critical,
that whole way of approach.
But-- so I think it's
great with Andris,
who is very comfortable in
both the concert as well
as the opera.
And we do a little bit
of staging, but not
too much because this is-- one
of the challenges of Symphony
Hall.
It's one of the smallest stages.
I mean, it's funny.
When we went to Carnegie and
took "Elektra" to Carnegie,
it's so much-- it's probably
twice the size in terms
of square footage of stage
and different-- so it's very--
we can do different things with
that than Symphony Hall where--
ANDRIS NELSONS:
But also, you know,
this is the privilege to do
like we did this year, "Elektra"
or "Salome" last year
or the year before, I
mean, with such a brilliant
orchestra as Boston Symphony.
You have to have a-- it's
so challenging, you know.
And--
MARK VOLPE: They're reading for
the orchestra being in the pit.
So you need a really great
orchestra to know how to--
ANDRIS NELSONS: You know,
so-- and in the meantime,
the challenge for--
to play, but also
a challenge to be not
overpowering all the time.
And the balancing
is very challenging.
It's actually [INAUDIBLE],
in particularly, you
know, we talk
about "Elektra," is
one of the most
challenging to balance it
in a concert version,
even in a stage version.
So, but this is all
exciting because-- and then
also the part that every
concert is different.
And you-- and that's-- I love it
so much that even we've always
prepare of course
for anything we do.
But there is this mystical,
unexplainable moment
of spontaneity, and not
planned spontaneity,
which-- but it just comes
because of the day-- today's
more sunny than yesterday or--
then your mood is different
than, the tempo's a little
different than-- you know,
I mean, this is exciting.
That's what makes it so great to
perform the same piece hundred
times and it always
will be different.
And I think-- and that's
why coming to concerts
or listening to concerts and, of
course, this great opportunity
to listen live or not live.
But you never find
two exactly the same,
performances of the same
piece, any orchestra.
ANDRIS NELSONS: Other questions?
Two questions back there.
AUDIENCE: So you talked
a lot about the emotion
of the music and your role as
a conductor to bring that out.
How do you balance
that with the fact
that you're rehearsing
every day and you
have to get the technique right
and like there's a-- Like how
do you keep that
feeling and balance
the kind of practical management
and practice and technique?
ANDRIS NELSONS: Yes, thank you.
It's a good question.
It's a-- because of course by
talking, you know, it's emotion
and it's a constant brain
activization and planning.
One can think, oh,
you know, how long you
can live like that because
it's a-- but this requires
a lot of planning of-- I
mean, for example, of my time,
so I know there's a big
inventive period of working.
And then I know I need
to recharge my batteries.
And of course the best ways I--
when other people say, oh, I'm
going on holiday,
whether they go somewhere
or they fly somewhere or--
when I say I go the holiday,
I go home.
I'm with my daughter
and I am with my wife.
That's-- it means, can be
as simple as just being home
and playing all day with my
daughter and going to have
a dinner.
And that's the
most exciting thing
after a big philosophical
journey of great operas
or symphonies.
And then again,
after that period,
you recharge your batteries
by living a normal life.
Because I think the music
at the end is also--
it is about our life.
It's not so much only about the
higher philosophical things.
Of course, there are always
questions and philosophy
and subtext and so on.
But at the end, it is
about what we feel.
It's about our lives.
The music it is about our lives.
So then living normal life and
the charging the batteries,
from there you come
back and you again,
you have something
more to say again.
So this is a contemplating of
your-- everyone has a different
kind of power and balancing that
the body and mental abilities
to-- But again this is a--
MARK VOLPE: But in terms
of technique, you know--
ANDRIS NELSONS: A technique.
MARK VOLPE: One of the things
about a Boston Symphony
that-- it's not
unique to Boston.
There are other, a handful
of other great orchestras.
But they come in, they
can play everything.
So it's-- Andris' focus is not
on, you have to play E flat
instead of E. If a
person-- they're mortal.
They make mistakes.
But that's just a
slip of whatever.
They don't make mistakes.
And--
ANDRIS NELSONS: That's of
course absolutely right.
What-- I mean, it's
a privilege having
a great, great, great
instrument, a great team
because with a huge, huge,
high level of professionality
which gives a great, of
course, great trust for me,
and then your concentration's
become more clear,
where you put your
energy and where--
how you divide your-- you put
your energy and emotionality
more because this is such
a, you know, jubilary
feeling to be in front of
these amazing musicians.
So of course, that's
also how you apply
in terms of the technique.
I also realize of course more
and more for the conductor,
even though it's very
mystical as a result,
but a simply clear
technique, whether it's
with beating or one or
other way or with your face,
but more clear expressions
through your hands
are always very helpful,
more helpful than talking,
let's say, to orchestra.
Because the orchestra
sometimes-- you
as the conductor
would think, OK,
so I would want to
explain-- I mean,
I know I'm talking now too much.
It's so boring
already, but-- for you,
but you know if you start
to talk to orchestras,
it's always, oh my god,
[INAUDIBLE] you know.
So they will say, please
show us what you want.
And this as cynical as that.
But something's-- it's
very important, you know,
the technique, the
manual technique.
So you can put-- you should
put everything in your hands,
in your face, also what
you're feeling in your heart,
you can express with
your hands, on your face.
You know, musicians can see
whether you are being very dry
and there is a beautiful
melody and you just,
you beating right.
Or your heart is also there.
And they feel it.
And that's-- also, you
need to have a technique
and the preparation.
And I also think-- which
involves a technical
preparation, professional,
and intellectual--
but I think it's also important
to train-- also to be--
to train the emotionality
as well, because you know--
MARK VOLPE: It's
interesting, you know.
We try to anticipate
possible roadblocks.
And you have these
younger conductors
who aren't nearly as
sophisticated and musically
and artistically
developed as Andris.
And we-- it might be
a Brahms symphony.
And we tell them-- and
then they sit there
and talk for 15 minutes about
the history of the Brahms
symphony.
You know, this is
orchestra that's
played it with Bernstein, von
Dohnanyi Mazur, Lavine, Ozawa,
Andris Nelson.
And it's like,
they're-- ballgame over.
I mean, they're professional.
They get through it.
But they have--
they're in my office
at intermissions at the first
break of the rehearsals saying,
what?
Whose idea was this?
I say, yours.
No.
I think one-- do we have
time for like one or two more
questions?
Anybody?
AUDIENCE: The need for
music, to some extent,
in developing emotionally
as a human person.
I'd be interested to
hear whether you think
this is especially
important in children
and, given that there
are many children,
whether it's for
economic reasons,
or you see political
instability in many countries
don't have access
to that, how would
you like to see the
BSO specifically
and the music community
in general help
reach children with that
beauty that they do need
at a critical age in
their development?
ANDRIS NELSONS: Yes.
Thank you.
That's very-- it's
very, very important.
Obviously what you say it's
very, very right and very
important, of course.
It's not only about
music as a-- you know,
as a privilege or as a fortunate
gift what God has given us,
some music or art or any--
But the music actually
can also be very much
like a-- I can't
say word medicine.
But it's like a comfort.
Like-- and there's
a-- as I say, I
mean, in particular
periods of life,
or particular groups
of people, or where
the music can solve many,
many problems and can help.
And I think by reaching
to those people
or those areas are of
course very important.
I mean, I know in
the Boston Symphony
there's a-- of course I met
several times a great team
of education department
who are co-planning
the special activities for
children and for younger
children, for very
young children.
There are involving
different things.
It's concert, but
also activities
like children trying
the instruments
or different ways of
activities, how they
can be in touch with music.
And these activities
are regularly
planned with the orchestra.
And of course, these are things
which in future and present
are very crucial, of course.
And I know of course
that from one side,
concerts and activities
happening in the Symphony Hall.
But they also activities where
musicians go to the schools
or to the communities to find
also the way to those children
or these people who can't
come to concert hall
simply because of several
reasons, you know,
or sometimes obvious reasons.
So this is very right
and very important.
I mean, we have to--
MARK VOLPE: It's very
out-- well, I'm sorry.
ANDRIS NELSONS: Oh, please, go.
MARK VOLPE: About eight, nine
years ago the then premier
of China was visiting
Washington, New York,
and Boston.
And I had the privilege
of sitting with him.
And I was curious
because I said,
it's a-- obviously, it's
a capitalist society,
but it's still strictly
controlled by the party.
And I was talking to him.
Why music?
Why have you invested so much
in this musical infrastructure
and pedagogy and physical
plant and all that?
And he says, when you
think about music--
and he was actually giving me
a lecture about America's lost
its way because they've
not seen fit to invest
in the same way-- he
says, rhythm is math.
Physics is acoustics.
I mean, that's what
we-- group dynamic is
if you're part of
an ensemble, you
have to subliminate
your ego and be part
of a greater good, a whole.
Then you start talking
about languages.
I mean, music is an abstraction.
It's a language.
And if you start
talking opera, they
come in six, seven languages.
So there's the language element.
Music is all rooted in whatever
historically was going on.
Beethoven and Napoleon,
I mean, obviously
had ambivalent feelings
at a certain point.
And it's not just
classical music.
It obviously goes far
beyond classical music.
And you look at the
negro spirituals and all
that as political statements
and how people have organized
their movements and that.
So the Chinese have decided
as a matter of public policy
that music, in terms of
training the next generation,
they don't need--
there's not room
for 60 million professional
musicians, even in China.
You know.
So-- but they believe, like
the Greeks and like the Romans,
but more the Greeks, that to be
educated you had to have music.
It's one of the
seven disciplines.
They always talk about
And music was one of
those seven disciplines.
And the Chinese are back there.
And you go to Beacon Hill
or you go to Capitol Hill.
And it's not clear our
political leadership
is as savvy and as intelligent
when it comes to such things.
So it's interesting
that music does
have a role beyond obviously
playing and emotionally
and connecting it.
It has played a political role.
It has played a social role.
You see where music--
it's interesting
that the most extremists of
what's going on in the Mideast,
they ban music.
And you start looking at some
of the fundamentalists who
are driving some of the--
it's pretty scary notion.
But music is
absolutely forbidden.
And that suggests something
in terms of the power of music
right there.
Thank you.
It's been a great,
great opportunity.
And I enjoyed the chat.
ANDRIS NELSONS:
Thank you, everybody.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]